[Music]
what's up everyone sydney goodman here
coming to you live from los
angeles california welcome to the game
awards pre-show
and please allow me to be the first to
thank you for setting down
cyberpunk for a few hours as you can
probably tell
the game awards are going to look a
little different this year
our venue may be smaller but the show
itself is as gigantic as ever
the awards and world premieres won't be
changing except i guess the only people
clapping will be me and probably
a few crew members going remote this
year will bring us musical performances
from
london and tokyo and one positive of
tonight's mostly digital gathering
is we'll get to see more faces in the
talented teams behind this year's
outstanding nominated games
as for us here in the pre-show we'll be
spending the remaining minutes before
the game awards kick off
with brand new trailers mercifully brief
integrated marketing and lynn will be
performing a song from persona 5
strikers
and best of all the big reason we're all
here
awards our first category tonight is
best score
and music it's a particularly strong
contest this year with five
standout nominees that could on their
own represent the best of the generation
here are the nominees for best score in
music
do maternal final fantasy 7 remake
hades ori and the will of the wisps
and the last of us part two and the
winner
is
final fantasy vii remake
as i said earlier you'll be seeing a
variety of different world premieres
throughout this pre-show
but strangely enough we've decided to
show you our most
important one first here it is
to the devolver digital 2021 game of the
year award
sponsored by devolver digital and now
your host devolver digital ceo
nina struthers
yes okay okay shush it so yeah tonight
we are here to celebrate this year's
most memorable
video games let's not overlook the
unrelenting hype not for this
but for next year's as yet to be
released games coming at you hot
from what many believe to be this
industry's most ridiculously overrated
publisher
while most of these games are months
away from release we at devolver digital
are strong
proponents of awards for award's sake
and with that the nominees for the
devolver digital 2021
game of the year are shadow warrior
three
by flying wild hog olea by skeleton
cruise
card shark by nerium
weird west by wolfi
[Applause]
boomerang x by deng
and the winner is
loop hero by developer four quarters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
four quarters couldn't be here with us
this evening as lupero was unannounced
until well just now really
let's have a look at loop herod
[Music]
mystical items to level up your hero
[Music]
break the spiral and save your world
loop hero coming in 2021
thank you yes oh hey thank you uh we'll
see you next year
or whatever
every year the game awards do our best
to highlight new games from all sorts of
developers from
aaa big shots like devolver to smaller
independent studios
our next world premiere is the debut of
a new game
from abu seb a young studio started in
new caledonia
enjoy
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
then
[Applause]
this next award category is for one of
gaming's most popular genres
action adventure the breadth of what is
considered an action-adventure game
also leads to this regularly being one
of our most competitive categories
incidentally for the past three years
the game award winner
for action adventure has gone on to win
game of the year so
this is a big one here are the nominees
for best action adventure game
assassin's creed valhalla ghost of
tsushima
marvel's spider-man miles morales ori
and the will of the wisps star wars jedi
fall in order
and the last of us part two and the
winner
is
the last of us part two wow we won
uh this is awesome we want to thank the
game awards for choosing us as the best
action adventure game
um on behalf of the directors which is
myself anthony newman and neil druckmann
we want to thank the entire team at
naughty dog who poured their heart and
souls
into this game it's really their talent
that immerses you in that world
and really makes you feel like you're on
this journey with ellie
uh i want to thank evan wells our
president
also everyone at sony and our partners
for really helping us
put this game together and get out the
door
and especially to our fans who supported
us
and uh really helped make this game
something special
you guys make it worth it so thank you
again
congratulations once more to the last of
us part two
we have many more awards coming up in
the pre-show but first
here's another trailer
hi everyone uh i'm connie i'm the ceo
and creative director of my games
company called yomai
in beautiful berlin it was such
an honor to be nominated for
the games for impact category at last
year's the game awards for our most
important project today
called sea of solitude i'm very happy to
announce
that sea of solitude will be coming to
nintendo switch
this winter but it's not just a port
we fully reworked the entire game we're
calling it the director's cup
because it's a version that truly
represents what i wanted to convey
about the topics that are especially
important in today's difficult times we
can't wait to share it with you
until then stay safe enjoy
the game awards and see you soon
[Music]
my monsters the path is full of stone
you know them too don't you the
they're waiting for us to capsize
[Music]
strangers
we'll face them
we'll chase them across the sea of
solitude
we'll set sail and we won't stop until
we reach safe harbor together
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready
we've had some great world premieres
already but we recognize there may be
some fans of elegant
shadow-based puzzle games who feel left
out don't worry
we've got something for you too from
focus home interactive
here is shady part of me
[Music]
there once was a girl who was trapped in
the dark
with naught but her shadow for company
a journey to escape she did embark
and her shadow followed distrustfully
girl found no hope in light
but despair her shadow smiled
with me there is a way
hand in hand we break free
from this nether step
by step we will rise
[Music]
together
you're just joining us now welcome we're
in the middle of what has turned out to
be
a jam-packed pre-show for the game
awards
we've just premiered two trailers back
to back and now
we'd like to take a moment to announce
the winners of three awards
first is best family game a category
that did
a lot of heavy lifting this year
throughout the months of what seems like
endless lockdown when pools closed and
chuck e cheese went bankrupt family
games were always there
the nominees are animal crossing new
horizons
crash bandicoot 4 it's about time
fall guys ultimate knockout mario kart
live home circuit minecraft dungeons
and paper mario the origami king
and the winner is
animal crossing new horizons
next i have the honor of awarding best
community support
this category debuted last year and it
represents
the games that truly value their player
base
demonstrated through communication and
respect here
are the nominees apex legends
destiny 2 fall guys ultimate knockout
fortnite no man's sky and
valorant and the winner is
fall guys ultimate knockout
finally we get to acknowledge the winner
for best debut game
this of course goes to nominees that
represent an independent studio's
first ever release it's an award for
fresh perspectives new ideas
and distinguished bravery the nominees
for best debut game
are carrion
mortal shell basmaphobia
raji an ancient epic and
roki and the winner is
basmaphobia
that's five trophies down and the game
awards haven't even
officially started yet as the handy
countdown timer says
we are minutes away so i'd like to take
a moment to let you know about a few
ways you can interact with tonight's big
show
all night long fans will be predicting
the winners on twitch
using a special voting extension powered
by verizon
5g built for gamers lock in your picks
throughout the night to see if you guess
the right winner
and whether you're watching on our
official channel
or from one of hundreds of code streams
mega drops will be activated for
fortnite
and among us over the last few days fans
have visited
are at the game awards tick tock channel
and voted
on which the last of us part two team
they support
team abby or team ellie the votes are in
and
team ellie won the vote thanks for your
votes and be sure to follow us on tiktok
if you haven't yet to catch
all our great gaming content we pulled
reddit's r slash
gaming community to see what their pick
is for 2020's game of the year
and the winner is go sushima
as for the game award for game of the
year we obviously won't learn that until
the end of the night
for now we're about to take a super
short break but coming up on the other
side
we've got winners for each of our
esports awards a persona 5 strikers
performance and of course
more world premieres
hey thanks sydney listen it's hard for
me to believe that it was
27 years ago that my brother robin and i
watched
players venture into the ages of mist
for the first time
anyway today i am so excited to start a
new chapter of mist
with the release of an entirely
reconstructed vr version
that's available now on the oculus quest
platform we've got
something special for anyone who
purchases mist
they'll unlock a mis-themed oculus home
environment i'm so thrilled for you to
experience mist and vr and
thank you so much for your continued
love and support
[Music]
welcome back to the game awards pre-show
for the first time ever
i get to introduce a musical performance
right here
in the pre-show and i'm not sure there
could be anything better to jump off
with
performing last surprise from the
persona 5 striker soundtrack
from tokyo japan here is lin featuring
the persona band
gamers are you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
think again don't you know what you
stuck to
[Music]
is
[Music]
you'll never see
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you never see it coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
at this year's tgs square enix
officially announced an update to 2010's
near replicant
the prequel to nier automata the actual
title of this remake was of course
another sick joke from director yokotaro
but the game awards pre-show will never
turn down a challenge
tonight i am both happy and unafraid to
introduce the gameplay debut for
near-replicant
version 1.2247-4487139
dot dot
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
it's been a special night already and
now i get to share with you
another game awards first the world
premiere
of a new band you heard me correctly
they're playing their debut
single follow unfollow please welcome
for the first time ever
o f k
[Music]
[Music]
behavior by tomorrow
[Music]
i just wanna dance
[Music]
i just i wanna dance
dance with you
[Applause]
um that's a bop
tonight's about celebrating all of
2020's best
in the world of gaming and that would be
impossible without honoring esports best
talent
who despite everything thrived and
continued to entertain and inspire
of the 30 different game awards
categories five
are esports awards we're about to
announce each winner but i
may need to call in some help to get
through them all we'll see
here we go for best esports game the
nominees
are call of duty modern warfare
counter-strike global offensive
fortnight
league of legends and valorent
and the winner is league of legends
for best esports coach the nominees are
krusty grabs rambo
zepha and sonic
and the winner is sonic
for best esports event the nominees are
blast premier spring 2020 european
finals
call of duty league championship 2020
iem katowice 2020
league of legends world championship
2020
and overwatch league grand finals 2020
and the winner is league of legends
world championship 2020.
for best esports host the nominees are
dash golden boy machine
shiver and shocks and the winner
is shocks
for best esports team the nominees are
dallas empire dam one gaming
g2 esports san francisco shock
and team secret and the winner is
g2 esports
congratulations to all of the winners
and now to announce the winner of best
esports athlete
here's the host of espn's first take and
the new espn plus show
stephen a's world stephen a smith
i know what y'all are thinking did they
just bring stephen a smith to the game
awards in an effort to legitimize
esports as something equal to athletic
sports
nah that's not the point they're doing
their thing
when every major sports league in the
nation shut down
esports just kept on going with that
being said
i'll say this much all of the esports
athletes nominated
are without question more determined
more tenacious
and definitely win more than anybody on
the dallas cowboys
now for our nominees crimsix
show maker kenyon
shotzi zai wu
and the winner is
[Applause]
showmaker
[Music]
you can definitely sense it right the
game awards are about to begin
stephen a smith just handed out the
final award of the pre-show
and now it's time for one last premiere
before the main show begins
and it's got something we could all use
a little more of
dragons fighting dragons here's century
age of ashes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and with that it means i'm about to sign
off
and hand it over to jeff look forward to
performances from eddie better and the
london
philharmonic orchestra will be playing
the traditional game of the year medley
as well as a special surprise
i love surprises there will be world
premieres from fall guys dragon age
super smash brothers ultimate among us
huge surprises little surprises and of
course
awards for the greatest games of 2020
this is sydney goodman signing off the
game awards start right now
hello everyone around the world and
welcome to the game awards 2020 we are
so happy to have you
joining us tonight you know this year of
course will be a little bit different uh
it's been a tough year for everyone i
know and
normally with the holiday season we'd
all be gathering with our friends and
family and
i know that can't happen for all of us
but tonight we can
gather here and connect around games
something that we all love games connect
us and i'm here in los angeles and
whether you're watching
live right now in china early in the
morning in europe
america my native canada wherever you
are uh even in
india this year all over the globe we
are coming together tonight
to celebrate our love of video games now
to keep everyone safe tonight
nominees are going to be joining us live
via zoom from all over the world you can
see them there hi everybody they're all
joining us from their homes and their
studios
china europe los angeles far and wide
and we will have all these guys joining
us
tonight as we get through all the awards
live in the show um we're going to be
joined also by some very special guests
keanu reeves gal gadot brie larson
tom holland christopher nolan john david
washington
the sweetest chef reggie and more and we
also have a very special performance
by eddie vetter from pearl jam he will
be in seattle and the london
philharmonic
orchestra from abbey road studios in
london conducted by lauren balf it is
going to be
an amazing show and as always we've got
the awards
we've got first looks we've got new game
announcements
all of the things that make the game
award special will be here
and what i love about this show is that
the entire industry
comes together tonight to celebrate
games
everyone is here or at least i thought
everyone was here
it does sound like we're still expecting
someone else
to arrive
uh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
all right the fun is just getting
started but of course this show is also
about awards and to present our first
award
you probably know her as captain marvel
she's an oscar-winning actor a filmmaker
and a dedicated activist and she's
joining us now
live on zoom it's brie larson hey brie
hello tonight i am honored to present
the award for best performance
among the nominees is an inclusive group
of talented actors filling vastly
different roles
in games that are nothing alike however
these artists are nominated tonight for
what they share in common
a clear dedication to their craft and an
extraordinary
ability to bring humanity and empathy to
their roles
here are the nominees for best
performance
best performance
the khan deserves to suffer
stupid boy you shall never reach the
[Music]
surface
don't be a hero miles okay
let's do this
and the game award goes to
laura bailey as abby the last of us
hurts you
oh man oh wow
um wow uh i
i was such a fan of the original uh
last of us and of troy and ashley's
performances within it
um i fell in love with julianelli
so it is no surprise to me that
uh abby's role within this story has
been met with such
uh passionate responses
but um to have been able to play
such a fantastically challenging
character
who through her story enables the player
to find
forgiveness and empathy is something
that i'll be eternally grateful for
um oh man i told the team on the day
that i finished filming
that what i wanted more than anything
was for my performance to
to give a performance that honored the
impact that the original game had on me
so this award means so much um
thank you to neil and hallie and the
entire team for giving me the
opportunity and for
all of the support and the guidance
along the way um
to patrick and ian and grace for uh
everything you did the the story and
abby would not have been as impactful
without you by my side
um to troy who
through our i don't know decades of
working together in this industry we've
been
we've been allies we've been enemies and
we've been everything in between
uh and every single time i work with you
i come away better for it
thank you for always having my back and
to ashley who i love
so much um i don't know what else to say
other than
um i think you should probably be giving
the speech right now i think
you're amazing and your your strength
and your power and your vulnerability
and your performance left me speechless
um i love you marry me
to my husband travis who spent countless
hours just listening to me come to terms
with
what this uh games journey has been
um and to the fans
obviously to everyone who voted thank
you for your support
and for your love and for your passion
and for
allowing yourself to go on this journey
with abby and with me
thank you i love you
congratulations laura i think i heard
imessages coming in for people
congratulations that was going on it's
uh
so great to have everyone here
celebrating an amazing year for games
alright we are streaming on every
platform tonight
including twitch where we have drops for
among us and fortnite who both have
world premieres
coming up later in the show and
throughout the night we will also be
interactive on twitch you can predict
who you think
will win using a twitch extension first
up best ongoing game so go and vote now
lock in your predictions all right well
even with everything going on it's been
one of those special years that sees the
launch
of new next-gen consoles and with that
brings a whole new generation
of games tonight we are honored to have
one
team a new team of veterans reveal the
very first details about their ambitious
and exciting new project
right here at the game awards enjoy
[Music]
pretty much since the day i started
there's been a really clear
player fantasy i think the thing that
makes it different from a lot of
first-person games is
it's not just about shooting eco sci-fi
is a term that we use
future fiction but from an ecological
focus there's been this ecological
disaster these corporations came in
and they developed new technology and on
the surface everything's
everything's pretty great we're still
early in development but we're really
excited with where things are going we
wanted to share a cinematic piece
that helps set the tone for our world
i remember when everything changed
the floods the storms the fires
people dying in the streets
the corporations gave us solutions
a better world
and we welcome them into our lives but
the laws of nature
aren't meant to be broken
we need to know what they're hiding
[Music]
[Music]
family
[Music]
did you find the answers you were
looking for
agent dark not yet
this is just the beginning
[Music]
there you go perfect dark from the
initiative xbox very exciting to have
that announced all right well
we're gonna go right into another game
announcement for the first time right
here
at the game awards check it out
civilians are required to stay in their
own homes for their own safety
take my life
there's too many stick together we got a
job to do
remember no worm ridden son of a [ __ ]
is gonna stop us
what the hell cover me
what is that take it out
oh man this is my favorite hoodie
a little club soda will take that right
out
watch out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
back for blood and i'm now joined by
chris ashton of turtle rock studios uh
this is
pretty exciting for all us left for dead
fans of course uh you guys are known for
all the amazing work
left 4 dead and now you're building uh
this on building on the legacy with this
new
zombie co-op shooter uh what's new what
can you tell us about it chris well
we wanted to do more and bigger right we
wanted to have
more playable characters uh more
missions
more story uh but we also wanted to have
a bigger variety of zombies to fight
right
but also we wanted to go bigger so now
we've got these 20 foot tall
zombie monstrosities that are definitely
going to take
you know the help of your friends in
order to defeat
all right well it's great to have this
game announced but it sounds like
i think you've prepared a little
surprise for everyone watching right
oh yeah like uh movies are cool but uh
gameplay is keying right
so let's see some of that okay here we
go here's the gameplay reveal
of back for blood thanks chris
ready not one for speeches so how about
we just go kill some rippers
goddamn here we go
watch out
for you and you
[Applause]
thanks holly
do these guys ever take a vacation
please just die already
watch out
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go back for blood june next
year
alpha next week crazy all right very
exciting well tonight we're celebrating
games and we've got
awesome discounts on many of tonight's
nominees with the game awards sale
across
xbox playstation nintendo eshop epic
game store
and steam we also have the game awards
festival a chance to play upcoming games
like little nightmares too
and some of the games are also available
instantly with geforce
now so make sure to check that out you
can stream on any device with no
downloads on geforce now well we also
have a lot of great stuff coming up
we'll have performances from the london
philharmonic orchestra
and eddie vetter but right now two years
ago we announced at the game awards
scavengers from midwinter entertainment
everyone has been wondering when they'll
get to play it for news on that let's
hear from mid winners
josh homes thanks jeff
i do have a really exciting update for
you but first i just want to thank the
many thousands of players who have been
testing the game with us
over the past year your feedback and
your support
means the world to us we couldn't do
this without you today
i have big news to share
explorers it's time
your face off against many others
there are countless strategies and
powers to success
find the ones that get you back alive
this is where the real fun starts i've
been preparing this for years
now i need you
people if you can see me
time to light the fire now it's going to
be a good time in it
everything is in place
your test begins
now
all right so there you have it the pc
closed beta for scavengers
starts right now if you're part of our
community
you can play with your existing steam
key but we're also opening up
50 000 slots for new players so go to
playscavengers.com
sign up for free and we'll see you in
the game
oh
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now
[Music]
you thought you could get rid of me but
you can't
anyways instagram the game awards have
teamed up for
six new ar effects you can share to
instagram reels
i played with them yesterday at home and
posted to the game awards profile
check it out you can transport yourself
to final fantasy 7's train station
transform into the doom slayer
don the mask of the ghost of sushima
sneak through the last of us or even
become
zagreus from hades to create your own
just head over to the game awards on
instagram
click on the effect icon and share to
instagram reels
and i'll be back later to show off some
of your beautiful creations
[Applause]
so
[Music]
there you go forza cross cyberpunk and
later keanu reeve johnny silverhand
himself will be joining us to present
the best direction awards so stay
tuned for that but welcome back now
coming up next we're going to present
the best ongoing game award and the
twitch
community thinks fortnite is going to
win that with 47
of the votes well let's find out the
twitch community is right
we're going to present the best ongoing
game which recognizes five
outstanding titles that continue to
deliver for fans here
are the nominees best ongoing game
here i go
our enemies stand no chance against this
power
all right well now it's time to reveal
the winner the nominees are joining us
here hi guys
all right here we go and the winner is
the game award goes to no man's sky and
i was not expecting that uh amazing
it's normally twitch is right jeff it's
normally fortnite
it's always fortnite that beats us uh
[ __ ]
uh thank you so much um we're
really lucky you know we get to come to
work every day and make games
no man's sky is such a wonderful game to
work on you know
and it's not always easy though uh so
moments like this they mean a lot you
know
this means a lot to me means a lot to
the team
thank you so much thank you to the
community for continuing to support us
thanks
congratulations sean murray no man's sky
best ongoing game
now every year leading uh into the show
there's always a lot of speculation a
lot of games that
you might be anticipating but there are
always a few you're not expecting
like this one check out this world
[Music]
premiere
uh
[Applause]
all right man get up
seeing this something right
uh
[Applause]
boys
this is black iron to transport ship
carry on
you are cleared for landing
[Applause]
i'm feeling some dead space vibes and
there's little wonder why you know him
from his work on dead space and call of
duty here's the ceo of striking distance
studios
glenn schofield hey glenn
hey thanks jeff well the crystal
protocol has been in development for uh
over a year and a half with a team of
well over 100 people on it
it's a single-player third-person
story-driven survival horror game
set in the year 2320 on jupiter's moon
of callisto
our goal is to make the single most
scariest game
for pc and consoles and we're so excited
to be able to show it here tonight
awesome thank you very much glenn we're
looking forward to hearing more about
that
next year all right announced back in
july warhammer 40k dark tide is a four
player co-op game from fat shark
the developers behind warhammer
vermintide 2. well tonight they're
sharing a first look at the gameplay
check this out
uh
big
now it is time to recognize some other
winners in the category of best art
direction
the nominees are final fantasy vii
remake
ghost of tsushima hades ori and the will
of the wisps
and the last of us part two and the game
award goes to
ghost of tashima congratulations to
sucker punch
for best action game the nominees are do
maternal
hades half-life alex neo2
and streets of rage four and the winner
is hades congratulations supergiant
in the category of best vr ar the
nominees are
dreams half-life alex marvel's iron man
vr
star wars squadrons and the walking dead
saints and sinners
and the game award goes to half-life
alex congratulations to valve for best
sports racing game those nominees are
dirt 5 f1 2020 fifa 21
nba 2k 21 and tony hawk's pro skater 1-2
and the game award goes to tony hawk's
pro skater 1-2
congratulations tony and for the most
anticipated game
voted on on twitter this year the
nominees are elden ring
there i said it god of war sequel halo
infinite
horizon forbidden west resident evil
village
and the legend of zelda breath of the
wild sequel
and your most anticipated game is
elden ring congratulations to from
software
alright this next game comes from the
creators of gone home in tacoma
the fulbright company in annapurna
interactive present one part road trip
one part mystery with two familiar
voices
check it out
my name is tess divine and the world is
passing me by
i guess as i get a little older i'm
starting to feel how things
change they decline and
go away that's how it was with my
grandma
i loved her so much i thought i knew her
better than anyone but looking through
her old things
we found hints of something she never
told us about
a man who wasn't my grandfather
a burglary ring some sort of
lost fortune we can't ask her about
these things anymore so
we have to go looking for the answers
ourselves
my mom and i are out on the road
searching
i don't know what we'll find but
whatever it is
i know we'll find it together
[Applause]
all right once again this year we're
excited to share some stories about
people around the world who are making a
positive impact on the gaming community
these are our global gaming citizens in
partnership with facebook gaming
our first honoree tonight is latinx in
gaming
check out this important story
when i was starting in the games
industry as a latinx person
i felt quite invisible it still feels
like i'm the odd one out
i felt alone i was often the only woman
and the only latina woman in the room i
think about how hard it was for me
to get where i am today and i don't want
anyone to go through that anymore
and welcome to latinx in gaming our
content our voices
linux and gaming is a group of people
that are dedicated to supporting
other people of latinx descent in the
gaming space the past three years we've
just grown
from a really small group into thousands
this was no longer just about game
developers this is about
streamers and students and journalists
and marketing
and fans pave the way for people like me
pave the way for people in our community
just knowing that there's somebody out
there doing
what you want to do empowers you to to
chase it
it's a really beautiful thing i'm trying
not to cry i was this close
okay
hey everyone my name is anna dolan i am
the executive producer of valrant and i
cannot believe that it has been only
half a year
since we launched this game our valorent
community has shown up in such a huge
way
helping us take this tax shooter from an
idea to a home
for tens of millions of players around
the world to celebrate this we've teamed
up with the game awards
to highlight one of the most vital
pieces of our community
honestly the ones that got us started in
the first place are valorent streamers
together we ran a fan vote to name the
best emerging valorance streamer from
our global community list
we'll announce the winner before the end
of the show and then we'll all go raid
their stream together
again i want to thank you all for
playing valorent and i'll leave you with
just a taste of what we've all done
together this year
the potential of ballarat i love it
oh my goodness
i got this
[Music]
[Music]
the slayer's time is now
you feel you are prepared now
for this
earlier today we tweeted out that there
is a special event happening right now
in pokemon go
well now's the time to bring out your
phones and start catching because we're
officially on
a whooper watch and they are so cute
we've partnered with our friends at
pokemon go to keep an
eye on the water fish pokemon and
throughout the night we'll let you know
when large numbers of whooper
will appear in the wild we've also been
told you could encounter
a shiny whooper if you're lucky so open
up pokemon go and catch some whooper
while you watch this evening
[Music]
get up detective one last
time
the great city at the end of the world
is waiting
so get out there solve the murder
with a unique skill system at your
disposal
carve your own path across an
award-winning
open world
and uncover even more in this
groundbreaking
role-playing game
meet and get to know more of the locals
welcome to reality baby sure thing champ
lead the way if you could only find your
gun
that's okay with full voice acting for
every single one
of the city's beautiful people
um yes i'm going to unplug the
microphone okay
and leave a bigger mark behind you in
new
quests you're big boys you can handle it
enjoy the definitive edition of this hit
rpg
disco elysium the final cut
a free upgrade for all players
welcome back to the game awards that's
so exciting disco elysium news you may
remember last year they were i think
they won the most awards out of any game
last year at the game awards so awesome
news all right
well now we're going to talk about
bioware's dragon age franchise it is
known for its story and its characters
and right now the team at bioware wanted
to give you a little sneak preview of
what to expect in the next game and
where it will take us
enjoy
[Music]
i face tyrants and would be gods
seen friends lose life and limb
but there's always someone bent on
breaking the world
it's time for a new hero
[Music]
no magic hand
no ancient prophecy
the kind of person they'll never see
coming
we've got your back i've got your back
demons dragons dark spawn
even the dread wolf
this is your story
all right we're back and i'm i'm trapped
in our set now i don't know what's going
on all right well
next we'll have a look at an exciting
new tactical squad-based
roguelite game set in the endless
universe here is another new
game announcement
are you dreaming or
are you living these same days
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
we'll be free
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Applause]
all right uh endless dungeons very cool
our next world premiere
comes from south korea crimson desert
the new open world
action adventure game from pearl abyss
this next gen game offers
in-depth story-driven single-player
content in an mmo setting
what you're about to see includes actual
gameplay footage
this is the beautiful and merciless
world
of crimson desert
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love having new ip and new teams on
stage
south korea that's fantastic crimson
desert all right now to present our next
award he joined me in fortnight earlier
this year the star of tenet
john david washington hey john
hey jeff thanks for inviting me to the
game awards
as you know in christopher nolan's
latest film tenet i played a character
called the protagonist
very literally named narrative and i
thought that was cool name for a
character it reminded me a little bit of
playing video games where
where were all the protagonists helping
to tell the story of the game with our
choices
great narratives and games are the
perfect balance of that feeling of being
in control but also being guided by
brilliant storytellers
and so these are the nominees for best
narrative
best narrative i told you
i have to finish it
i will sacrifice everything for my home
a touching reunion
can't be real
and the game award goes to the last of
us part two
oh my god okay this is the first
award acceptance speech i've ever done
so i wrote it down so i wouldn't mess it
up but okay here we go this is amazing
um first off it's such an honor to be
nominated with so many incredible games
that came out this year
so truly truly um of course i've got to
thank my co-writer and the director of
the last of us cartoon neil druckmann
who was courageous enough to tell such a
ballsy story
um and a big shout out and thanks also
to our other writers um
josh cher and ryan james and of course
the entire naughty dog studio
this game is what it is because of the
collaborative nature at that studio and
their love of narrative
and of course thank you mostly and
always to the fans these characters
meant
so much to us and we're really touched
that they resonated with you as well
so thank you right now we've got a very
special guest who has some exciting news
for all you virtual chefs out there
joining us all the way from his kitchen
it's the swedish chef chef are you there
[Applause]
for the city picking the number one
[Music]
i'm so sorry to cut you off and you're
looking sharp in that tux by the way
and my swedish it's a little rusty but i
think there's been uh a little bit of
confusion
honestly no no no it's for the win
thank you for the shooting cuban de
frugi
if we're taking all the shooting froggy
from the sheen no no chef i i'm so sorry
but you
didn't actually win a game award that
trophy you've got honestly it kind of
looks like
leftovers anyways you're supposed to be
sharing an announcement here
uh about a co-op game no
co-op game like a fun cool new game with
a playable character named swedish chef
yes that is why you're here for a world
premiere
let's take a look
[Music]
and there you have it what do you think
chef furnitures
for the picking the number one oh
[Music]
oh my uh all right well congratulations
to the
swedish chef this time it's real swedish
chef is playable
in overcooked all you can eat on ps5 and
xbox 36 and he's available
is presenting our games for impact award
and we'll head to abbey road studios to
celebrate mario's 35th anniversary
with the world famous london
philharmonic orchestra
but right now let's hear from dr lupo
about a new initiative at the game
awards
future class hey y'all i'm dr labeau and
tonight i'm honored to partner with
gillette
to introduce the game awards future
class a group of thinkers
dreamers and pioneers who represent the
bright bold and inclusive future
for video games
games have really changed my life to be
honest with you my name is royce payne
i'm a senior computer science major at
morehouse college and i'm currently
playing on the morehouse marine tiger
gaming team
we see other big colleges able to have
these gaming teams
and they're winning scholarships for us
not to have it we were like
this is a lack we need to get rid of
this lack
we're just a collection of hbcus who
have different passionate gamers who
want to compete against one another
we played against some good competition
so far just being able to really break
into that space and open the door for
others to come behind me that's
huge for me
[Music]
oh hi everyone i hope you're enjoying
the game awards i'm alana pierce coming
at you live from
my mansion as someone with a chronic
respiratory illness i've had to find
some unique ways to deal with
20 20 situation like maybe i go for a
swim in my
olympic sized that's not olympic the the
olympic one is indoors so
but i know that there are some people
out there watching this that are
depending on things like
vaping to try to calm themselves down
however the high levels of nicotine that
you can be inhaling can actually worsen
your anxiety
and just kind of fight against the
mental health battle that is
this year not that i would know because
you know but that doesn't mean i'm not
trying to look out for you
for those of you who are looking to quit
vaping which i hope you are
this is quitting is a free text-based
program with a free built-in support
system
text game awards to 88709
[Music]
oh i want that mario music back that was
fun all right back in 1997
i wrote a story about two game
developers coming together to make an
unreal franchise tonight
they're teaming up again for this epic
game store world reveal
which you can play right now
[Music]
operator our armaments of
possessing a tactical advantage have
increased test those weapons
accuracy is
[Music]
any casualties are enormous your
progress
in line with projections
[Applause]
welcome back to the game awards earlier
i asked you to head over to instagram to
post our game of the year ar effects to
your reel
let's check out a couple of your
creations
looking great keep posting on instagram
and i'll share some more in just a bit
now back to your host jeff keely
thank you very much sid last month call
of duty invited players
to unravel a conspiracy decades in the
making with the release of black ops
cold war
on december 16th season 1 kicks off free
multiplayer maps more weapons and more
operators and for war zone players a
massive update of content including a
new
close quarters map rebirth island here's
your first look at the gameplay
of season one
that where's chasing ghosts he has some
pieces of the puzzle
but doesn't know he's a piece himself
he won't live long enough to work that
out
[Music]
vengeance is
you have no idea what's coming
we are in control he's trying to bait
you out
no [ __ ]
i won't show him the mercy
is mine
we knew this year that the game awards
orchestra wasn't going to be easy to
pull off but
we had to try i know how much we all
love video game music well i'm really
proud
of what we've got for you right now this
is an anniversary year
the 35th anniversary of nintendo's
all-time classic
super mario brothers originally released
in 1985
here to perform a medley of mario songs
from the legendary
abbey road studios in london this is the
world-class
london philharmonic orchestra led by
conductor
lauren balth enjoy
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
that kind of makes everything better
doesn't it wow uh thank you to lauren
and the london philharmonic they'll be
back again later in the show
and eddie vetter's coming up too so lots
of shows still to come
lots of us are in lockdown right now i
know it might feel normal tonight to see
all these games but
we're all on lockdown and i know we all
can't wait to go back outside
to travel the world meet new people well
until then
here is a game where you can do all of
that as you explore and record
disappearing cultures
in a strange beautiful world this game
is just stunning and it's coming to
playstation 5.
check it out
trump
our grandparents lived for a thousand
years
and our parents had a century to
[Music]
themselves
but us
we have one season
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful that's seasons all right well
now it's time to present another
game award she's the star of the
upcoming film wonder woman 1984
here is gal gadot hey gal
thanks jeff i'm honored to be here at
the game awards
lots of video games are fun to play but
each year
a select few games deliver a deeper
message
they focus on subjects that can be
historical
political or deeply personal the games
for
impact award honors socially progressive
projects
that have the potential to inspire real
change in the world here are the
nominees
[Music]
games for impact
nothing good comes from stirring up old
memories we don't really have a choice
about that
we knew we had to resist no matter
the cost and the game award goes to
tell me why
hi all i'm livi hall the community
manager and tell me why
and on behalf of the entire team from
both dontnod entertainment and
xbox publishing thank you so much for
this award and thank you so much for all
the love that you've shown tyler and
allison
and their journey i'd like to express
our team's deep admiration for all of
tonight's nominees
especially those that have used their
platforms to
tell stories about trans and queer
people
with sincerity and heart here's to a
future where even more marginalized
people can see themselves
and their experiences truly reflected in
the games they play
thank you so so much
congratulations everyone's joining us
live the tech is working this is amazing
and it's so cool to see everyone
um all right well right now we've got
another brand new game announcement for
you
check this out unexpected
it's time to go
um
[Music]
but um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
lights out old friend
[Music]
yeah that's right arc two starring vin
diesel and the team at studio wild card
has one more announcement for all arc
fans check this out
can you feel it the balance of nature
has been altered
there is someone out there who may
change our fate
who could lead us out of the darkness
and yet i wonder hunter and alone
on this strange new world will she be
able
to survive
[Music]
what
good boy
[Music]
[Applause]
it has been a crazy year for fall guys
it became a
massive phenomenon and we all had fun
with it uh this summer especially when
we were all in lockdown this holiday
season
fall guys is back with a winter
wonderland for season three
here's your first look
[Music]
jingle and everyone telling you be
of good cheer it's the most wonderful
time
of the year
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the half happiest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they'll be scary stories and tales of
the glories of christmas
[Music]
the game festival is going on right now
and you can stream all the game festival
demos using any device uh
you own with geforce now you can check
that out uh the game festival lots of
amazing games you can play
all weekend long all right coming up
next tom holland
nolan north and the award for best
multiplayer more awards and
announcements and later
we've got reggie keanu reeves plus eddie
vedder from pearl jam
playing his song from the last of us
part two but right now
elite dangerous is a space sim mmo from
frontier
players have been exploring the galaxy
for nearly four decades
here is the gameplay reveal of odyssey
which lets you explore on foot
for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
ground control to major tongue
ground control to make your tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on this is
[Music]
[Applause]
and the stars look very different
[Music]
today
we all need a way of coping with what's
going on in the world
games is an incredible way of doing that
i'm jennifer hazel i'm a medical doctor
when i started specializing
in mental health specifically something
clicked i realized that
all my life i'd been using video games
as a way of nurturing my own well-being
and i wondered if other people could do
that too
hi this is and so i established
checkpoint to bring mental health
resources
to the gaming community what is mental
health we use
games as a medium to raise awareness
and to reduce stigma and to provide real
tangible resources to people who are
struggling that they can use
in their everyday life
[Music]
above all else i want people to know
that
it's okay to be struggling at the moment
there are resources out there
and it will help and it will get better
welcome to enoch a hell hole of madness
and misery
if you don't want to end up as worm food
what worked for you in the old world
won't work here natural running
and hiding are simply not viable options
here if you plan on surviving you need
to shift your mind into a higher gear
so let me walk you through the mantras
of survival
could i have your attention please first
cover is for cowards yeah that's right
you can use cover nobody's stopping
but you're a biological sledgehammer act
like one
chuck yourself into the fray two your
powers are on tap
you feel that tingling in your
fingertips
your powers are ready to be unleashed
don't keep them waiting
three you've got to kill to heal
there's no use licking your wounds want
your health back
get out there and take it violence
breathes in vitality
finally a guiding philosophy to end
you have to think aggressive
[Music]
the tinder could be a threat you better
think twice
before you hand it to them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
i've got you
under my skin
i've got you
deep in the heart of me
it's all deep in my heart that you're
really a part of me
i've got you
under my skin
hey what's up guys it's uh tom holland
here i am in atlanta on the set of the
next spider-man film but i am honored to
be a part of the game awards tonight
you know that for the past few years
i've been working on the uncharted movie
which did involve some extensive
research playing
the games i'm honored to be playing
nathan drake what i can assure you
is that we really want to honour naughty
dog's amazing games
so this film tells you how nathan drake
became the character we all know and
love
it's now my honor to introduce my good
friend nathan drake please welcome
mr nolan north
[Applause]
thank you tom i could not be more proud
of you you know someday when someone
searches for nathan drake on imdb
and you are the first result i will only
be remarkably bitter
you know video games allow us to connect
with friends
family and complete strangers we can
share memorable experiences beyond the
confines of our own homes
or even travel to vast new worlds with
our buddies on the couch next to us
of all the years i've been grateful for
multiplayer games they've never been
more important to us than they were in
this historically
crappy rotten no-good cursed year
these are the nominees for best
multiplayer
best multiplayer game presented by
instagram
[Music]
[Music]
and the game award goes to
among us
oh thank you so much oh my god
oh i can do this all right thank you
game awards and everyone who voted for
us
um and also congrats to all the other
games nominated
um it's an honor to have won best
multiplayer category
our goal among us from the beginning was
to create a fun experience
amongst friends uh two years ago among
us started with
local mobile and then um online and pc
and the rest is history now more than
ever finding ways to connect with
friends is increasingly significant
and we're so happy many of you turn to
among us to play
with friends and family big thank you to
robot teddy duel studio and our other
partners
for helping us navigate all the
excitement thank you to our moderators
and the fans who have been on this
journey with us for the past two years
and big thank you to our friends and
family you've helped us
test and been incredibly supportive
through it all thank you so much
thank you thank you
tonight you've been using instagram's
custom game of the year arfx to add
a snazzy trophy to your reel let's check
out a couple of those
you're all winners in my book keep
making those trophies and i'll be back
with more later
now back to jeff all right thanks very
much sydney
and congratulations to intersloth later
among us
among us the new map reveal all right
now we've got another brand new game
announcement
this one is fun it's one of your
favorite supernatural horror franchises
and it looks like a bloody good time
check it out
[Music]
i had a real life once
i had a wonderful girlfriend linda
together we drove to a small
cabin in the mountains
mortis the book of the dead
it seems an archaeologist had come to
this remote place to translate and study
his latest find
it was never meant for the world of the
living the book awoke something
dark in the woods
took linda
and then it came for me
[Applause]
there you go evil dead the game next up
a classic game franchise
is being remade take a look at this
[Music]
announcement
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
we love ourselves some capcom arcade
classics we're now going to recognize
some more
winners in the category of best
independent game the nominees are
carrion fall guys ultimate knockout
hades spelunky 2 and spirit fire
and the game award goes to hades
congratulations super giant
for best audio design those nominees are
do maternal
go to tsushima half-life alex resident
evil 3
and the last of us part two and our
winner is
the last of us part two congratulations
naughty dog
for best role playing game the nominees
this year our final fantasy 7 remake
genshin impact persona 5 royal wasteland
3
and yakuza like a dragon and the game
award
goes to final fantasy 7
remake congrats square in the category
of best
simulation or strategy game those
nominees are crusader kings three
desperados three here's tactics
microsoft flight simulator and x-com
chimera squad and the winner is
microsoft flight simulator
congratulations
and in our fan category player's voice
you voted tournament style to pick your
favorite games the final five nominees
were
doom eternal ghost of tsushima hades
marvel's spiderman miles morales and the
last of us part two
and the winner as you may know we
announced it online congratulations to
sucker punch
ghost of tashima now we've got one more
for you this is for best fighting game
and here to help us out from netflix's
cobra kai
two great rivals from film history ralph
macchio
and yuji okamoto hey
what's up game awards game awards what's
up
hey ralph you know who wins this no how
would i i mean we haven't even read the
nominees yet not you
because i'm not in a game oh come on you
were in a game
karate kid for nintendo 1987.
and yo karate was weak all right yuji
listen whatever okay why don't we just
read off the list of nominees huh
right best fighting game grand blue
fantasy versus mortal kombat 11 ultimate
street fighter 5 champion edition
one punch man a hero nobody knows under
knight
in birth and here we go the game award
goes to
sorry it's this thing is stuck
somebody glue this thing i got you macho
and the winner is mortal kombat 11
ultimate congrats you guys awesome
all right congratulations to mortal
kombat and thanks to ralph and eugene
one of the things i have really been
missing this year is flying around the
world but
luckily we have one of the most
beautiful games of the year to help fill
that void a little it just won
best simulation strategy game microsoft
flight simulator and next year
it's coming to xbox here's what that's
going to look like
it's an airborne view of our wonderful
[Music]
world
[Music]
i see trees of green
red roses too
i see them blue
[Music]
foreign
as i think to myself
oh yes
all right uh microsoft flight simulator
looks amazing coming next summer to xbox
and now it's time to take a look
at another game coming to playstation 5.
check it out
my end is waiting at the beginning
i will go there now
the crash every time what is this
cycle i'm trapped inside
[Music]
another end another beginning
[Applause]
all right we will be back in just a
moment with a ma'am amin
a man a meme a legend reggie he's going
to join us
we've also got a new look at a game from
a guy you might remember from one of the
craziest most unscripted moments
in game awards history joseph faraz plus
eddie vetter will play his song from the
last of us part two
and later jacksepticeye joins us from
europe to present content creator of the
year
presented by adobe lots of great stuff
coming up here on the game awards we
will see you
right after this
[Applause]
what are you training for what will you
do with this strength
my answer to this question used to be
simple
it's not so that i continue winning
i train so that i never
lose again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
super meat forever
[Music]
so
[Music]
hi i am mary mauser along with peyton
list from netflix's cobra kai
we're here to settle one of the great
rivalries in gaming this is abby versus
ellie from the last of us part two
i am team ellie ellie is probably one of
the greatest game characters of all time
yeah and abby can beat her up so that
makes abby better team abby all day
what oh yeah she's like a perfect
physical specimen if she gets a nap and
some food in her she could probably
dead lift a small car and she's nice to
dolls well ellie is an artist and a
beautiful singer
abby could be a good singer you don't
know yeah you can tell she's not a good
singer point snipers don't make it
serious
honey is it you
how far are you from the border
be careful with the people that give you
a ride
and and don't travel with someone you
don't
we love you honey
[Music]
so
[Music]
times
[Music]
[Music]
everyone welcome back to the game awards
and before we went away there i might
tell you that was a look at a new rogue
coming to rogue company um so make sure
to check that out uh this holiday season
all right
well you'll probably remember this next
developer from a few years back he is
not a fan of the oscars but he is a fan
of colorful language and our show he's
in stockholm sweden tonight
and he wanted to give us a new look at
his next game here is
my buddy he really is my friend joseph
ferris hey joseph
what's up jeff so nice to be back at the
game awards
as you can see i'm in the middle of a
mocap shoot
working on our next game it takes two
trust me when i say this
hazelites next co-op only experience it
takes two
it's gonna blend narrative and a huge
variety of gameplay
never done before and today we're gonna
have a
gameplay reveal a word exclusive i know
you like word exclusive
but this one is even extra exclusive my
man
anyway we're also gonna have something
that we had in a way out we call a
friend's pass which means
you buy one copy you get one copy for
free
you know if you play with your friend
you can play with free with free
for free i mean with free anyway it's
coming out
march 26th enjoy the trailer goodbye
boom
[Music]
this is the story of a magical king
one of wizards and worries
bobsled sort of thing you know
where did i mention the big explosion
all the writing look at these dolls
almost forgot they used to be humans
do you want to know what this story is
really about
huh this is the story
wanna change back then you need to fix
your relationship
[Music]
you're a doll cody you've nothing to
throw up
i told you
i feel stuck
how do we break it okay i got this give
me some space i need to think
[Music]
foreign
how comes you get all the cool gadgets
just behind you yeah what are you doing
you're not feeling it
no okay you're entitled to your own
opinion
[Music]
[Applause]
what an absolutely crazy game joseph
showed that to me last summer when i was
in stockholm i'm like we have to show
this out there's so much gameplay there
thank you for that joseph
all right now i'd like to welcome a
longtime friend and supporter of the
game awards he was there
in vegas for our very first show back in
2014 and he's been back
every year since we weren't going to let
the streak stop this year the retired
president and co from nintendo of
america
but still a boss regifizame reggie
jeff jeff how you doing i'm doing good
reggie take it away
absolutely you know i'm proud to present
the very first award for innovation
in accessibility during my time at
nintendo
we had a mantra gaming for the masses
and we pushed that agenda with we
nintendo ds
and now nintendo switch but today
approximately
1 billion people around the world
experience some form of disability
that makes gaming challenging for them
this award was created
to highlight the efforts throughout the
gaming industry
to make software and hardware that
enables games to be played and enjoyed
by the widest and most inclusive
audience possible
because gaming is for everyone
here are the nominees
[Music]
innovation in accessibility
[Music]
and the award goes to
the last of us part two
hello i'm matthew gallons and this is my
fellow designer and neighbor emilia
schatz
and from everyone at naughty dog we
would like to thank you so much
for honoring us with this year's
innovation and accessibility award
thank you as well to the game awards for
choosing to add this category and
to all the other developers who have
designed and advocated for accessibility
in our games
we hope that together we can continue
the momentum to push our industry
forward
as developers we know how one small
design decision can unlock
the entire game for a player games are
special
for their ability to blur the line
between player and character
providing a means for personal
engagement with narrative that is
unrivaled
in other artistic mediums it's up to us
to ensure that everyone can experience
that for themselves
we'd like to thank our terrific group of
accessibility consultants
and we'd absolutely could not have done
it without your your insight and your
your detailed feedback thank you
we'd also like to thank our partners at
worldwide studios
um our senior producer sam thompson the
user experience research team
and our dedicated accessibility qa
testers
and we'd also like to thank everybody at
naughty dog
this was truly a team effort and every
department had a part to play
in removing barriers for players with
disabilities
lastly we'd like to thank you the
players nothing makes us prouder
than hearing stories from players who
are able to experience the last of us
part two
without assistance using our
accessibility features to remove
barriers that would have otherwise
excluded them
from both of us thank you so much
thank you
congratulations to naughty dog such an
important category and i'm proud that
we're able to recognize innovation and
accessibility here at the game awards we
do that every year moving forward
this next world premiere gives us our
first glimpse at next year's big
adventure for the elder scrolls online
[Music]
enjoy
yes
from imposters and among us to the
visual beauty of gen chin
impact mobile gaming has had an
incredible year coming up i'll be
revealing the winner of
best mobile game presented by lg wing
the world's first
5g swivel smartphone powered by qualcomm
snapdragon
and later the first look at a brand new
map
from among us the game awards will be
right
[Music]
the back between light and dark is so
very thin
let's cross it together
fate comes knocking sooner or later with
this
power we make our own face
[Music]
all right then load up
[Music]
our fight is far from over
[Music]
the guardians will come through they
always do
stay alive
[Music]
i am a highly trained persistent spies
there's something wrong with this place
received your distress call the council
did
hey your pirate friend stopped by while
you were out
don't be silly you'll never make it
[Music]
go now
[Music]
tonight go to wdblock.com to get one of
the fastest internal ssds on the market
the sn
850 nvme ssd with heatsink
[Music]
we've just heard from our friends at
pokemon go that there is
another surge of looper appearing so
we're implementing
another whooper watch bring out your
phones and get to catching and if you
haven't heard
pokemon go recently implemented its go
beyond
update which introduces quarterly
seasons raises the level cap to 50
and makes earning xp easier for everyone
pokemon originally discovered in the
kalos region
like chess pin fennekin and froki
are also making their pokemon go debut
there's also a lot of bonuses happening
now
and it's never been a better time to
play pokemon go they've always
known you would come
do you know why you have
secrets lies
dangerous things if you are to face
what's coming you must find your full
voice
to present our next award she's a host
and producer from ign
and your host for the game awards
pre-show this
is sydney goodman
[Applause]
mobile games were once defined by their
limitations
in a way we celebrated the games that
excelled despite their platform
as technology has closed the gap
releasing on phones is no longer
a limitation it's an asset it's never
been
more apparent than tonight where the
nominees for best mobile game have found
massive audiences because of their
platform
here they are best mobile game presented
by lg wing and qualcomm snapdragon
now i take to the sky
and the game award goes to
among us
[Applause]
thank you again game awards and everyone
who voted for us
uh and congrats again to all the other
games that were nominated um
we originally designed our game among us
to be played on mobile devices
so if you found yourself with a group of
friends you could easily set up a game
we wanted our game to be accessible at
any level of gamer and wanted to create
a fun experience to be shared amongst
friends
and family and whoever
we want to think our players first and
foremost among us would not be
where it is today without you um
whether you played among us when it was
mobile local only
or played for the first time just
yesterday thank you from the four of us
um again big thank you to robot teddy
duel studio and all of our other
partners
for helping us during all of this
um and thank you to our moderators and
the fans who have been on this journey
with us for the past two years
and a big thank you again to our friends
and family we love you and miss you
and thank you for being so supportive
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much
congratulations to among us second win
of the night
next up the monster hunter franchise is
coming to nintendo switch in 2021
this is a new look at monster hunter
rise
a huge pack of monsters in a giant
stampede
they attack the village in a frenzied
rage
nobody knows why this happens but it
came close to wiping out our village
last time
[Music]
oh too cute
[Music]
we need you to protect kamura village
all right over on twitch the next poll
is for content creator of the year
vote now for who you think is going to
win and we'll find out a little bit who
wins that category
but next up he's one of our industry's
great performers and he plays joel in
the last of us
here is troy baker
one day on the set of the last of us
part one neil
our writer and director asked me and
ashley what we would have been
if we weren't actors i thought about it
for a second and replied that
i always imagined i would have been a
singer ashley just shrugged and
in her charming and off-handed way said
i would have been an astronaut
neil incorporated parts of us into ellie
and joel
space and music became major elements of
their stories creating touching moments
between them
one of those moments now indelible in
our memories
incorporated neil's story as well
not as a writer but as a father it
involved a song he would play and sing
to his daughter
every night that song was pearl jam's
future days
one day neil asked if i was comfortable
playing it in a scene he was writing for
the last of his part too
now i don't generally get nervous but
i understood what that song meant to
neil and to the game
and the truth is neil can play that song
better than me
but nobody can play it better than the
person that wrote it
from seattle performing future days
here's eddie vetter
[Music]
sometimes you'll succeed to make this
man of me
all my stolen broken parts
i've no need for anymore
[Music]
our future days two days
[Music]
back when i was feeling broken
i focused on a prayer
you came deep as in the ocean
did something out there here
all the complexities and gains
no one wins but somehow they're still
played
all the missing crooked hearts
they may die but in us they live
on i believe
[Music]
and i believe cause i can't
[Music]
and cyclones raised when when
turned dirt to dust when floods they
came in tides they raised ever
close to became
[Music]
all my demons used to come around
i'm grateful now they've left
so persistent in my ways
hey angel i am here to stay
no resistance no alarms
please this is just too good to be gone
i believe
[Music]
me
you and me
all right so that was the song future
days
and um that that song you might
recognize from from the last of us and
um i really appreciate the way that was
that was used um especially bringing
joel and ellie together uh
connecting through music and and i
thought maybe it was cool too that made
you
want to perhaps pick up a guitar
yourself and and write a song for your
loved one
um but uh it is nice
to be part of this uh show my
appreciation and be part of this year
game awards
and um what a fascinating way to
tell a story it's just getting better
and better all the time and
it was cool to be part of it so thanks
for having me
and enjoy the rest of the show
doesn't get better than that thank you
so much eddie better for being here
on the game awards all right now here's
another brand new game to show you
for the first time
you can run
for a long time
let me tell you the news
foreign
down
there you go evil west all right on
twitch we asked you to predict the
winners and content creator of the year
and the twitch audience uh said valkyrie
with
44 of the vote they think is going to
win so the award for
content creator of the year is coming up
next presented by adobe and artist boss
logic
used adobe creative cloud to create
tributes to the nominees you'll see
those in a minute
and we've also got announcements from
among us and fortnite
but right now scarlet nexus is an
upcoming action jrpg
from bandai namco here's a look at the
brand new trailer
[Music]
the virtual brainlink cable will now be
connected
this will hurt much more than it did in
training be strong
good seems like you're okay
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
[Music]
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
i wouldn't let that happen
focus
play it on the all-new xbox
for me i am often depressed when i look
at the status of where we are in terms
of depression
and anxiety and inattention we owe it
to all the people that are suffering to
be really creative and to try things
that when you first hear it
sound crazy like a video game as
medicine my name is adam gazali
i am a neuroscientist and a neurologist
it started for me 12 years ago i became
really interested in this idea of
creating
experiences as a way of improving brain
function
and this relies on a principle called
neuroplasticity the fact that our brain
reshapes itself and modifies itself in
response to challenges
and so that's how it all started for me
to create a video game
that was carefully designed to challenge
and reward the brain in a very specific
way
and so what just happened a couple of
months ago the fda cleared endeavor rx
as a medical device to treat inattention
in children that have adhd
this is the first time ever that the fda
has cleared a video game for any medical
condition
so what we're talking about right now is
to have a video game prescribed
just like we prescribed pills for
conditions and
think about this as a new type of
medicine
the world is a dangerous place
only the best can keep it safe
become a tier one operative
plan position
and execute
do whatever it takes to neutralize the
threat
join the elite bring the thunder
thunder tier one
as gamers you are just generally better
humans and the world needs you
here at the peak humanity procreation
facility gamers from around the globe
are donating their superior dna
i'm donating i'm donating i have
powerful swim swims and it can be yours
transcend humanity through gaming
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Music]
welcome back and as you just saw ea play
is available now on new consoles steam
and origin it includes star wars jedi
fallen order
one of our nominees tonight and a great
game all right now on to one of the
biggest games this year was created by
three developers in seattle now four you
saw them they've won two awards tonight
intersloth they absolutely took over the
internet with among us well they sent us
something special this
is the reveal of the brand new map
for among us check it out crewmates
[Music]
welcome recruit get yourself acquainted
with the layout of the top at airship
enough slacking go to your tasks
you may need to take a ladder to get to
certain areas or maybe just take a nice
shortcut
quit grouping up choose a room to start
in after a meeting
someone keeps trying to sabotage us stop
their plan
keep your eyes peeled we definitely have
an impostor here
[Applause]
all right the among us team has another
surprise they've turned
my face into a mask and that drops right
now on twitch for the next 30 minutes
that's right
the jeff keeley mask have fun don't be
suss
they they came to me i said all right we
can do this one of my requests
anyways uh oh my gosh jeff keeley match
now available
all right he's a hilarious content
creator with over 25 million subs
and over 13 billion views he's joining
us now
live from the uk jacksepticeye hello
jack
what's up hello jeff how's it going
hello everyone at the game awards
in a year when so many of us were
separated from our family and friends
one thing remained the same our favorite
content creators were still there for us
their streaming gaming and sharing
helped us fill the hours
and feel connected unifying us all with
our shared
passion for play here are the nominees
for content creator of the year
content creator of the year presented by
adobe
are you proud of me dad wonder who is
this man in my face
what's your baby
wait hold on wait hold up hold up wow
wow wow wow put my crown on
yes i did
and the game award goes to
valkyrie congratulations
thank you so much to uh the gabe awards
for
nominating me and to all of my friends
and family and fans and my
loving community for being so supportive
of me
uh the past seven or so years of
streaming and now
to uh being creator of the year
that's crazy because there's just so
many amazing
creators i can't believe i don't know
it's just
unbelievable anyways thank you so much
for the support
i am very flattered and honored to
accept this award
um and yeah
thank you adobe salutes the nominees for
content creator of the year at the game
awards
and all gaming creators around the world
tonight celebrate your creativity by
downloading a free trial of adobe
creative cloud
at tgaxadobi.com and get creating
joining me right now is the chief
creative officer of epic games
donald mustard uh donald it is great to
have you on the show it's a yearly
tradition
new fortnight season what can you tell
us
oh man so awesome to be here so awesome
to see you
this is amazing jeff you did this yet
again uh
uh so yeah i was so excited right now
new season has started we just
all battled galactus together with our
favorite marvel heroes and
what that's done is it's left the
fortnite zero point exposed and agent
jones is
looking for all these hunters throughout
all these different realities that can
uh help him stop anyone from escaping
from fortnite and
we've already seen several characters
come in and we have one more
that he's bringing in right now
[Music]
master chief comes to fortnite you're
getting them all donald
isn't that crazy like master chief is
just one of my
most favorite characters ever in
anything and i'm just we're
so thrilled that he can join the
ever-growing cast of characters in
in fortnite uh and the coolest thing is
he's going to be available
tonight uh in fortnite you can go and
and
get master chief and i know there's some
more halo coming as well i heard
yeah so i think uh you know we didn't
want to stop right there
and so there's something else i think we
should uh we should check out
well hello sir it's an honor
hey sarge did you hear oh i guess you
already got the news
what news master chief is coming to
fortnight afford what now
it's only one of the most popular video
games in the world
but more obviously it's where we are
right now wait a minute if you had no
idea that we're in fortnite then why do
you have a cardboard cut out of master
chief
perfectly regular reasons whoa
you guys new around here no the chief
got eliminated by a sneaky blue
that's no blue that's that's ninja
it's such an honor i'm a huge fan of
yours on twitch
twitch is he twitching cause he's blue
stop making us look bad in front of
ninja
we're sergeant griff from the popular
web series red versus blue
you probably watched it about 10 years
ago what are you doing here
well it's more than just the chief
coming to fortnite this map is too
it'll be in creative mode starting at 10
a.m eastern time tomorrow
oh so that's what we're doing in
ragnarok you mean basin
i'm pretty sure it was called something
else either way
you can start reliving your favorite
halo memories here in fortnite and maybe
add your own personal touches to the map
hey wait does that mean we can have
dance battles
come on ninja what do you say uh
save it for new year's
red versus blue donald
[Applause]
yeah isn't that so awesome and so funny
um
so what's awesome about that is that uh
blood gulch was recreated in fortnite
creative
by this awesome creative team that call
themselves atlas creative
and tomorrow at 10 a.m eastern
you'll be able to go into fortnite and
you can play capture the flag in a
recreated version
of blood gulch oh my god it's gonna be
fun everything
is in fortnight right now so are you
done for the season
you know i mean agent jones is uh is
actually just kind of getting
warmed up so uh i think there's actually
one more thing that we should show you
[Music]
thanks doll i have no idea where we're
going next but i'm on board
thanks jeff all right donald mustard
from epic games all right come up in a
moment keanu reeves is going to present
the award for best game direction
we've still got a few more surprises
don't go anywhere right now
let's hear from rocket league on their
new season
hey what's up this is cascade and i am
stoked to be welcomed into the rocket
league's vibrant community in such a big
way
i'm excited to work with psyonix and
monstercat to put together
an ep for rocket meets music season
season 2.
starting tonight you can get the
featured anthem in the item shop and
grab my free banner
all weekend long let's check out the
season 2 trailer
featuring my brand new track that i made
just for you guys
and i call it flip reset
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing's gonna stop me
[Music]
so
[Music]
he really doesn't give up
carry it up
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hey what is everybody
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
just checked pokemon go on my phone and
there's whooper
everywhere so we can officially declare
another
whooper watch team go rocket grunts are
also appearing in balloons and at poke
stops
and you can save shadow whooper from
their villainous clutches
make over your buddies take photos of it
with go snapshot and battle with it
in go battle league if you're enjoying
whooper watch you'll
love pokemon go's december community day
happening this weekend
and be sure to check twitter after the
show to see how many whooper have been
caught
globally during whooper watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
honey you picked the wrong time to get a
[Music]
drink
[Music]
[Music]
the game awards is back we've got a lot
of great show keanu reeves still to come
christopher nolan and so much more and
of course we've got the game award sale
happening on all the platforms including
an
awesome discount on destiny 2 so uh make
sure to check that out across all
platforms all right for the next 30
minutes on twitch
you can get a free cosmic wrap for
fortnite there is a twitch drop
happening right now let's check that out
too
this next game was announced last year
right here at the game awards
developed by airship and supported by
riot forge and now they're back to give
you a first look at the gameplay from
this indie title
the first ever single-player console
game from the league of legends universe
this is ruined king a league of legends
story
cutthroats spirits
monsters when you live in bilgewater
you see some things
let's start the party
the queen of bilgewater looking to bring
order to this twisted town
and stay down the priestess of the great
kraken
unmoved by fear this is destiny
the legends whose strength is only
eclipsed by his kindness
feel better now
the terror from the deep who preys upon
the living
you won't feel a film
[Music]
and a nine-tailed box who devours the
essence of her victims
[Music]
i see no fortune for those standing in
their way
can't match my blade can't help but
wonder what brought them together
[Music]
nothing good i reckon
[Music]
[Applause]
all right rune king available on console
and pc in 2021
now to present our next award a man who
absolutely needs no introduction please
welcome
keanu reeves keanu jeff
thank you greetings everyone i'm honored
to be here to present the game award for
best
game direction this category recognizes
the studio that demonstrated superior
creative vision
setting an even higher bar for the
entire gaming industry
over the past months i've come to really
appreciate all the fantastic creativity
that goes into making a video game
a special shout out to the folks at team
at cd project
red and poland i had an amazing
experience playing johnny
silverhand in cyberpunk 2077.
thank you and now here are the nominees
for best game direction
best game direction this is a one-time
gig
when it's done we're done
and the game award goes to
the last of us part two congratulations
amen uh thank you keanu that's
a surreal thing to say uh shout out to
our game directors kurt marganow and
anthony newman
wish we could be doing this together
guys man what a year
um it's an honor to be in this category
with such
incredible games direction has nothing
without a team to internalize it make it
their own and turn it into a game
and we're privileged to have such an
amazing team
cast outsourcing partners our partners
at sony
every single person that worked on
touched this game helped shape it
and a big thanks to my former boss now
partner evan wells
you guide us through thick and thin uh
while we made this game
uh i can't tell you how much i
appreciate that thank you to the game
awards and to all our fans
cheers
congratulations neil all right we've
still got one last award to present the
big one
game of the year presented by
christopher nolan and will also have a
tribute to
all the nominees performed by the london
philharmonic orchestra back
at abbey road studios game of the year
is coming up
next but right now gta online continues
to evolve and next week they've got
their biggest update yet
check this out
[Music]
is this the right place for the party
can we post is there a hashtag
[Music]
we're all here because of one man you're
not on the mainland now huh
anything goes i've seen him going in
like a trout
chasing some supermodel down the beach
on a panther
[Music]
you're obviously going to need a
submarine
let's try and come out of this with all
of our ears
[Music]
lucy adam was born about
9 000 years before our time
in the year 515 after having federated
the african continent
she set out to conquer rome it was on
witnessing the consequences of this
terrible battle
that she decided to impose upon her
people as strictly a
vegetarian diet
and it's in 1082 following the
unexplained death of the king
that she was crowned empress of spain
it's in fact to celebrate this event
that uh rock and roll was invented
in 1789 allied with the valiant japanese
she discovered the real indies which had
fallen into the hands
of the bloody french
[Music]
this was followed by the great
devastation
a 100 year war that lucy adam ended
before beginning the great
reconstruction
and establishing a lasting peace by
banishing
all forms of currency and violence as
well as the use of
selfie sticks in museums lucy are you
with us
okay so for next week don't forget your
essay on
the cultural stereotypes of the great
civilization
how far will you push humankind
we've been having fun with instagram's
game of the year ar effects
here are a couple more those effects are
still available so keep posting to your
instagram reels and coming up we'll find
out who's getting a
real life game award trophy for game of
the year
well [ __ ] how bad have things gotten
the german occupation has turned every
neighbor into a possible enemy
we need more resistance members but
that's much easier said than done
drop your weapons make any move and we
should
please tell me you brought bazookas
okay that's a piece of shrapnel
we had to report for the dress it was
something we had to do
you want to hear the rest of the story
we all know it's going to be a tough job
ahead where is my sister
but it's good for us to be together
that's all we can ask for
welcome back to the game awards i'm so
excited about that medal of honor
from respawn in vr surprise it's out
right now what an incredible trailer and
game i can't wait to play that
hopefully this weekend all right when
the show ends the games continue with
the game awards festival you can play
upcoming games
and stream them on geforce now which
means no downloads on pc mac
or or phones uh make sure to check it
out uh we got playable games available
all through the weekend
all right we've got one last world
premiere to share with you
check this out
[Music]
we know now that in the early years of
the 20th century
protocol
is
just
[Music]
[Applause]
mass effect i can't wait to see where
bioware is going to take that
uh next um very exciting all right well
to present our final award
this man has created some of the most
iconic films of all time
some of which screen this summer in
fortnight and on december 20th
i'll be sitting down for a conversation
with him on youtube to talk about the
home release of tenet
and his illustrious career and if you've
got questions for them which i'm sure
you do
send them our way using the hashtag
asknolen on twitter
but right now without further ado to
present game of the year it's my honor
to introduce
christopher nolan hey chris
thank you jeff it's an honor to be part
of the game awards for me
i've always been interested in telling
stories that immerse the audience i like
movies that
unfold in unexpected ways and pull
people into a world
when i look at video games i see a lot
of parallels with that kind of
storytelling
uh how players agency and choice
intersect with
more traditional storytelling methods
it's uh exciting to see
and really quite groundbreaking tonight
all six nominees for game of the year
are true masterworks in immersive
storytelling to pay tribute to them
please welcome from abbey road studios
the london philharmonic orchestra
conducted by my old friend lorne belfie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well that sounded fantastic and now the
game of the year award
goes to the last of us
part two
uh again a big congrats to all the other
games were nominated with
um everyone at naughty dog
i i can't wait to hug and high five and
get drunk with each one of you
that's gonna have to wait till next year
um
i want to just thank every person that
worked on this ambition game
within nine dog and outside uh shout out
to our
sony partners again scott rhodey connie
booth herman
paul sean laden jim ryan your support
and trust in us
means the world and more than anything
and i know that i speak for the whole
team when i say this
we'd like to thank our friends and
family that stood by us and supported us
throughout
us making this game you inspire us not
only to make better
more meaningful games but to improve how
we make games
on behalf of everyone at naughty dog
thank you
congratulations to naughty dog game of
the year for the last of us part two and
congratulations to
all our winners and all the nominees
around the world
thank you for joining us virtually and
next year hopefully we will all be back
together in person in the meantime
there'll be plenty of games to play
congratulations also to pluto who is
voted by the fans as their favorite
emerging ballerina streamer
let's all go raid her stream right now
on twitch there's also the twitch gaming
post show that's coming up right now
at slash twitch gaming i'll be joining
them to chat about all the things you
liked and you didn't like in tonight's
show
it's been a very unique year but one
thing that never changes is our passion
for gaming
and the games we love thanks to our game
awards team
and all the incredible developers and
publishers around the world
who made this show possible under very
trying circumstances i can't believe we
did it
take care stay safe happy holidays and
be well
i'm jeff keeley good night we'll see you
next year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you